um i'd like you all to ask yourselves a
question which you may never have asked
yourselves before
what is possible with the human voice
what is
possible with the
human human
[Music]
uh
baby
[Music]
yep
it was coming straight for me i had to
it was
yeah as you can probably
well imagine
i was a strange child
um
[Applause]
because the thing is i was i was
constantly trying to
extend my repertoire of noises to be the
very
maximum that it could be i was
constantly experimenting with these
noises and
i'm still on that mission i'm still
trying to find every noise that i can
possibly make
and uh the thing is i'm a bit older and
wiser now and i know that there's some
noises i'll never be able to make
because i'm hemmed in by
my physical
body there's things it can't do there's
things that no one's voice can do for
example no one can do
two notes at the same time you can do
two-tone singing which um
monks can do which is like um
[Music]
but that's cheating
and it hurts your throat
so um so there's things you can't do and
these limitations on the human voice
have always
really annoyed me
because beatbox is the best way of
getting musical ideas out of your head
and into the world but they're sketches
at best which is which is what's annoyed
me if only
if only there was a way for these ideas
to come out
unimpeded by
the restrictions which
my body gives it
so i've been working with these guys
and
we've made
a machine we've made a system which is
basically
a live
production
machine a real-time music production
machine and it enables me to using
nothing but my voice
create music in real time as i hear it
in my head
unimpeded by any physical restrictions
that my body might place on me and
i'm going to show you
what it can do and before i start making
noises with it
and using it to manipulate my voice i
want to reiterate that everything that
you're about to hear
is
being made by
my voice this
this system has
thank you beautiful assistant
this um
this system has no sounds in it itself
until i start putting sound in it so
there's no pre-recorded samples of any
kind
so
once this thing really gets going and it
really starts to mangle the audio i'm
putting into it it becomes
not obvious that it is the human voice
but it is so i'm gonna take you through
it bit by bit and start nice and simple
so the polyphony problem i've only got
one voice how do i get around the
problem of really wanting to have as
many different voices going on at the
same time the simplest way to do it is
something like this
by dancing i saw this
[Music]
me
thanks
so that's
that's probably the easiest way um but
if you want to do something a little bit
more immediate something that you can't
achieve with live looping there's other
ways to layer your voice up there's
things like pitch shifting
which
are awesome and i'm going to show you
now what that sounds like so i'm going
to start another beat for you like this
[Music]
there's always got to be a bit of a
dance at the start because it's just fun
you can flap along if you want
you don't have to it's fine check it out
i'm going to lay down a bass sound now
[Music]
guitar
which is nice but what if i want to make
say a uh
like what if i want to make say a rock
organ is that possible yeah
it is by recording myself like this
[Music]
and now i have that
i have that recorded
[Music]
assign it to a keyboard
so that's cool
um
but what if i
what if i wanted to sound like the whole
of pink floyd impossible you say no
it is possible and you can do it very
simply using this machine it's really
fantastic check it out
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
so
[Music]
so every noise you can hear there
is my voice i didn't just trigger
something
which um sounds like that there's no
samples there's no synthesizers that is
literally all my voice being
manipulated and when you get to that
point you have to ask don't you um
what's the point why
why do this
um
because it's cheaper than hiring the
whole of pink floyd i suppose is the
easy answer but in actual fact i haven't
made this machine so that i can emulate
things that already exist
i've made this so that i can make any
noise that i can imagine so with your
permission i'm going to do
some things that are in my mind and i
hope you enjoy them because they're
rather unusual especially when you're
doing things which are as unusual as
this it can be hard to believe that it
is all my voice you see it can be hard
to believe that people my voice
um
[Laughter]
like this
[Applause]
[Music]
so
me
um
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
um
[Applause]
so
loosely defined
that
is what's possible with the human voice
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
you